congratulations on this did you take the
job so that you could play endless hours
of halo and call it research yeah
absolutely that was my number one thing
just just play video games for free for
research how daunting was it though to
get to actually book the job because
master chief is a character that i'm not
to tell you this but people love and
have love for a very long time there's a
whole lore around him yeah it's iconic
it's an iconic character and you know a
huge part of that comes from the fact
that when you play the video game you
play as him so there's a part ownership
that everybody has over the chief
because you know you you use him to play
the game yeah um so from the moment i
got cast i could i knew it was going to
be a big deal i knew there was going to
be a lot of feelings around it i knew
there was going to be a lot of opinions
around it
and that's all just part of the part of
the funds and i'm just happy for
everyone to get to see it silver team
on me
[Music]
we're all we have now i'm sure that you
went through like multiple iterations of
the suit and the armor and so it sort of
like came together into the final
version over time but when you saw
yourself in the final version of the
suit what was that feeling like it was
amazing the the moment i remember is we
were about two weeks before we were
shooting we were in budapest and they
had kind of kept the the costume secret
from from most of the crew they hadn't
showed anyone and um uh on this one day
they put all four of us into our spartan
costumes for all the four spartans from
silver team and marched us out in front
of the crew and showed everybody you
know for the first time in unison uh us
marching as a team and you could just
feel it you know you look out from those
helmets and you just see everybody's
reaction so many people that were in
that crew had been working on it for a
lot longer than i had you know and so it
just uh it was a great moment where
everyone just kind of felt like it was
finally happening are there a ton of
pictures of you guys like making flexing
poses or like doing the mr universe or
whatever it is i think there may be some
like daps or whatever you know but uh
but but no the more amusing photos are
the ones in our big camp chairs we have
these massive oversized camping chairs
that like the fold out four post camping
chairs because you can't fit in any
other chair
except for these like you know massive
texas-sized chairs so heavy the chair no
the
chair's heavy it took like two prop guys
to carry it out for us the armor's heavy
has about five it's actually not that
heavy it's 55 pounds which you know
isn't all that much weight but when
you're carrying it for 14 hours
obviously it adds up but more it's that
it's in it really makes you quite
immobile it's hard to get your arms
above your head it's hard to move your
hips so it just um it limits your
mobility so so figuring out how to you
know bring it to life in an authentic
way is definitely part of the challenge
now between master chief
uh
who we got we have porn stash we've had
uh
yeah mad sweet i mean the william on
lawn or like a ton of a ton of iconic
characters and performances but have you
and your brother considered teaming up
for something
it hasn't been on my radar and i don't
believe it's on his but uh i'm a huge
fan of is he's a fantastic actor so it's
always uh you know it's just nice that
that we are getting to support our
families and you know make a living at
the thing that we love to do so i
certainly wouldn't turn my nose up at it
or shake my head at it but it hasn't
come across our desk we'll put it that
way
you